League fans have been absolutely fuming
this week about how a single skin is set
to cost them two hundred dollars and how
this may just be the start of something
many have been dreading for years
[Music]
alright so the culprit that has kicked
off this whole uproar has been dark
Cosmic Erasure gin it's essentially a
chroma for dark Cosmic gin which was
released back in 2019 but is being sold
as its own skin it has a few new color
streaks going on but doesn't really
bring anything particularly new compared
to what we first saw four years ago but
the anger hasn't been about what the
redesign actually offers players it's
been about how they actually get the
skin players will need to open dark
Cosmic Erasure capsules to work their
way up to the new gin skin at 30
capsules each of them costs 750 RP
meaning you'll need 22.5 K RP in total
that comes out to almost 200 US dollars
now there is a chance that each capsule
could just give you the skin about a one
percent chance but to absolutely
guarantee you'll get it you'll have to
slide right about two stacks now if
you're used to the likes of Cs go you
might be wondering what the B deal is
here 200 bucks for a skin isn't that
crazy elsewhere but the reason League
fans are so annoyed here is that first
of all this is a chroma a slight
re-brush of an existing skin for 200 and
of course like all League skins it's
non-tradable but more importantly
because it takes League one step closer
to a place that many have feared to go a
gacha game now a gacha game is many
things but it's most defining
characteristic is this you cannot simply
buy an in-game item that you want oh no
the term gacha comes from gashapons or
gacha pons toy vending machines popular
in Japanese malls and arcades which will
pop out a mystery prize in return for a
few coins and it's that mystery that's
at the heart of all of this you may get
something you want for your money but
you also may not gatro mechanics have
been creeping into the gaming world for
the better part the last two decades now
particularly within the fantasy genre
but with a few exceptions many have
resembled something closer to a pop-up
scam than an actual video game game but
that perception finally shifted with
2020's release of gentian impact a fully
realized AAA game that made its first
billion dollars six months after release
everything in the game is locked behind
a wish system which involves multiple
types of in-game currency it never
requires you to spend real game money
but the temptation to do so and spin
that wheel of chance has left many
spending far more than they would have
initially intended to do so and so how
does this all lead back to the Gin skin
in League of Legends well here you have
something that can be obtained by
opening a random loot box but the odds
of that happening are so low that you
essentially have to Fork over 200 to
Riot in order to guarantee you get the
skin it's capture mechanics are
indefensible and actually Riot haven't
tried to defend what's going on here
they've simply tried to shape the
narrative in their blog post on the
topic they said this is part of their
new Mythic variance system which is an
answer to the limitations of the current
Prestige skin model essentially these
skins were becoming too numerous and
accessible which actually made them less
attractive to players who want to spend
big to ensure exclusivity so these
insanely exclusive new skins that may
take a player two hundred dollars to
obtain are no accident they're designed
to cater to a very real corner of the
player base and although the rest of the
community may not be happy it's the
exclusivity Chasers who are speaking
louder if you get what I mean part of
the problem here is that while you can
call Ryan greedy if you want to what you
can say this is a money grab from them
while you can fear that League's home
screen May one day look like just one
big slot machine this still isn't pay to
win we're still talking about a skin
that has no tangible effect on gameplay
we've seen expensive skins in the past
granted this one is about six or seven
times more expensive than anything we've
seen before but as long as Riot doesn't
allow the size of a player's wallet to
dictate their in-game success they're
probably going to continue with this
monetization model now that is in no way
a defense of Riot I personally feel like
they're kind of taking the piss by
offering such a small redesign for that
price tag but if people are willing to
pay that kind of money then they're
going to offer it to them simple as so
where is the line here do companies like
Riot have a moral obligation to limit
how much a player can spend on a skin
because some skin Chasers will be
financially irresponsible that's a hard
case to argue for a much easier argument
to make is this does this new skin
system Mark a clear step towards
gambling in League of Legends does being
able to pull a lucky role and get a skin
earlier than statistically expected
constitute gambling and if it does a
league fan is happy with that the new
Jin skin don't get me wrong that's pure
evil any loot that is is random right
that it has a randomized route to it is
like uh at least a cousin to gambling if
not gambling by itself and this is still
a game for kids and it's still deeply
uncomfortable about that kind of stuff
in a Reddit post last week Riot bright
moon said they'd heard complaints but
that they had no plans to change the
rollout they maintained that this skin
and the more to comb like it are
intended to answer a rarity ask from an
incredibly small percent of league
players while reassuring fans that Riot
will never sell power to give players
willing to spend more a competitive
Advantage now from the outside it does
seem like League fans are making a whole
lot of fuss about a single pricey skin
and I have seen a lot of people out
there shrugging their shoulders and
saying look if you don't like it nobody
is forcing you to buy a 200 skin but as
we've seen it's much more than that many
fear that this is a slippery slope for
League of Legends that if Riot likes how
this gacha model Works players could be
rolling the dice on a lot more things to
come
[Music]
an Irish one I think that would go quite
thematically yeah of course he's a
friend of the pub or something yeah yeah
yeah a friend of the locals that'd be me
for another regulars